leur dis en face à tous ceux qui pensent
on a sorti sur twitter voilà ce que
du temple et des dépôts du tout découle
comptes évoqués alors les délais vous
raisons différentes c'est vrai que
jugement étudiants à des étudiants
oil et non moi je suis pour une société
baisser c'est tout dépend où on écrit
fait vous vous engagez contre emmanuel
conférences avaient des mois d'être viré
vous étiez quasiment entrant en train de
ceux qui pensent à au front national ou
pense mourad boudjellal de rmistes
ça et qui votent front national je leur
prévoir
menaces pourquoi pourquoi parce que les
pouvez pas alors je vous dire c'est un
en fait rien que tous les messages que
étrangers moi je suis plutôt fier qu en
aujourd'hui ces derniers hivers précaire
inclusive je crois on est une grande
delphine a été très affecté par son
macron oui c'est moi je le parie sur wii
ailleurs mais ça s'appelle simplement la
rmistes français est un anti c'est à peu
diffuser des propos à la limite et
bordel pas possible je sais quel est le
dis en face regardez vous vous êtes
france on ait de grandes écoles de
à regarder bien dessinées ou la vérité
famille bien sûr que tout ne va pas bien
budget effectivement on est dans le même
des jobs hyper est pour bat kinsey
j'ai reçus en fait il ya une première
définition du racisme aussi ça
médias ont fait leurs choux gras de tout
problème et si on prend liberté google
raciste regardez vous vous être assis
je sais pas vous mais de fait elle
grandes universités et qu'on forme des
haineux moi ça m'a dérangé parce que
vague de messages très positif à la
bien sûr sur les jets les jeunes ya
près le même genre de manipulation là on
bateau on est vraiment ce que je vois
personne n'en parle jamais et c'est
n'irait pas vrai c'est parce que je
maintenant je sais qu'à une typologie
ça en fait ils ont découpé des choses je
étudiants étrangers et qui se disent
beaucoup de choses à dire je suis
vraiment une aberration c'est une
que les voulait les coûts liés au non
direct des lecteurs ou au rassemblement
tous les deux ce que je vois c'est que
suite de l'émission quand les gens ont
vous rendez compte ou pas ils vont dire
brad on ne compte pas dire et je vais
est sur une très alors je te répondre
trouve pour arnaud d'avoir donné pour
d'accord avec vous sur le pass sanitaire
c'est en france que je vais venir
pense qu'ils n'ont pas regardé tout le
vous êtes raciste si vous pensez que les
moi de boudjellal il vient tous les
aberration et vous le savez très bien ce
tous les deux voulaient tous les deux
regardé le le direct en entier et puis
national qui vont voter marine le pen
pourquoi pourra pour avoir le savoir
puisque ces 10 secondes qui manque ne
tpm p ils ont découpé et au sauna lille
de bras à tour de bras faites le savoir
ya beaucoup de choses à dire je suis
jours il est chroniqueur et on va faire
une once et bien sûr ses saillies et oui
ne serait pas le premier à faire appel à
vous dire je veux dire là maintenant
d'accord avec vous mais le président
mon opinion second médecin d'avoir donné
on va être avec l'outil de calculatrices
origines ont une incidence sur
parce que c'est en france qu'il y à le
ou est ce qu on le situe donc moi par
on dit elle fait la promotion de marine
avec le la venue de mourad ce soir on va
parce qu'ils sont déçus parce qu'ils ont
des cabinets de conseil il peut y avoir
change pas le sens pourquoi ils ont pas
emmanuel macron il a pas eu au moins il
sont des râleurs aujourd'hui la pareille
savoir je suis pour rien c'est dans leur
ensuite il ya eu une deuxième vague que
une crise parce qu'il ya une crise
cette réunion gracieuse mais tu as dit
mais c'est ça ce que sauf que on sait
exemple en 2017 j'ai voté emmanuel
n'a pas eu un un mandat facile on est
14 minutes 22 demain il faut que tu te
laissé ma vie pourquoi les ont pas
débat la nasa il ce n'est pas le fonds
l'attitude vous êtes raciste à tous ceux
le pen mais en fait c'est pour
sociale qui est très dur qui est très
faire les
je veux que ce soit la maman des
du négatif à la suite de tous les
laissés c'est simplement que le
tous d'accord pour le reconnaître crise
fort y en a aussi qui vont voter marine
macron je suis très très déçu et je peux
trouves un mec serenthia il a fallu
programme leur juste une charge de
roannais ont vécu ça va faire pareil aux
déjà ce qui s'est passé pendant cinq ans
mis un terme à la dic des platines et de
français ça veut dire que tu veux que ce
rassemblement national a voulu me faire
moi je suis une 6 juste une citoyenne
qui votent front national à tous les
articles que les médias ont sous les 1
sociale léger donc et gilet jaune
précise pour assemblée nationale si vous
carbone et des comptes et pas du tout si
vous dire pourquoi je suis très déçu
le pen parce qu'elle n'a jamais été au
soit notre présidente après si
donc voilà je suis d et mourad en même
dire ce que anvers en vie que je dise
pouvoir c'est quelque chose que j'ai en
grandes gueules série
bien l'ipad
donc aujourd'hui qu'est ce que je vais
coordonner des cabines égard les
élus du front national à tous ceux qui
n'avait l'egypte à nice à une guerre non
décidez de virey 600 mille étrangers de
qui est déçu si je faisais la promotion
technique pas parce que les gens
temps pour voir pour essayer il ya là
j'apparais tu es courageux suis déçu des
temps je sais qu'on commande m'y
l'entretien je connais mieux les
pour défendre leurs électeurs en leur
de marine le pen j'aurais peut-être fait
faire au 2e tour voter blanc c'est un
regardent très mal comme moi je pense
les gars vous dis la vérité ça va ces
nient s'être assise une partie de la
600 mille logements sociaux juste une
à la pandémie c'est la seule chance il
reprendra plus parce que je suis déçu de
manuels pas congeler n'y ait pas de
aussi qu'ils vont voter marine le pen
chiffres sont incroyables si vous vous
la promotion de cette candidate au
peu compliqué donc je vous pose la
missions vous moi c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
disant regardez il ya un méchant qui
souci mais ne dis pas que je rate ma dit
parce qu'ils n'ont pas supporté qu'on
est jeune et non l'équipe est jeune
population jour et nuit si vous pensez
la société star c'est autre chose je la
qu'on est aussi c'est exactement le
informez vous verrez que le problème
chose ce soir il va falloir nettoyer le
mais on vous l'avait révélé temps et
question est-ce que vous pensez que
quatre jours oh tu veux ça va viendra
c'est pas de sa faute c'est le résultat
leur mette un pass bac sinal et je les
problème c'est que les mecs ils mike
vous agressent qui vous traite de
que tu étais pour marine le pen parce
premier tour ce que je n'ai pas fait
c'est moi qui dis donc si moi je vous
c'est raciste non pas du tout mais je
société start-up que voulait le
studio on va tous y mettre une manière
c'est qu'il y a une pensée unique il ya
de deux dizaines d'années de 2,2 de
que s'il ya eu d'autres rural est une
raciste et nous on vient vous défendre
que ça c'est pas vrai mais attends tu
l'un d'entre eux est sur twitter il met
dis non c'est non non alors je vous dis
lundi où on n'est pas les mecs ça va
président l a été compliqué à mettre en
sauf que maintenant au deuxième tour il
origine oui c'est bassiste
là du coup venait d'aller dans le sens
vais vous répondre par une chanson de
l'as dit tu écriras je suis là fasia les
une dictature de la pensée qui fait
respecte tout à fait moi moi moi moi
un titre mourad boudjellal insulte les
place pendant cinq ans parce qu'il ya eu
nullité des femmes et les hommes ça
voilà c'est la technique comme l'avait
de jil puisque vous venez de dire pardon
c'est pas c'est pas non plus franchement
laurent fontaine louis bat bernard
vous êtes un exemple de réussite moi je
vraiment froid dans le dos parce que on
ya une personne où il ya une autre on a
kassav quand tu emprunte le chemin de je
mangas et c'est pareil moi vous vous
pas mal d'événements qui sont arrivés et
venir l'instant finalement raison change
c'est pas de sa faute dans les ateliers
électeurs du front national laisser ça
montiel ont servi à la vie un peu le
déjà laissé une personne ça ne me
peut pas réfléchir sur les programmes on
une punition extrême et je suis une
qui font que je trouve que c'est déjà
père marquette sont clos son temps et
le colis tu sais pas mais a fondé on est
derrière les mecs regarde même pas
j'adore voilà ce que tu as fait tu le
avez été pour macro vous l'avait défendu
de la vitrine mais l'arrière boutique
l'extrême droite ange qui habitués à
alors ça c'est un marchand et on va voir
m'en fous tu arrives au village de si
correspond pas pour ces raisons là voilà
l'extrait et s'est scindé faire le bon
des comptes et quand ils opèrent au
pas mal macron était en marche et
sais on s'en est souvent parler c'est
le gilet jaune fut bouclée manifester je
gens pareils a été un héros clair vous
j'avais su et dimanche soir ou lundi
émission d'un bijou ça
est tout de suite jugé et moi c'est ça
point soleil s'est donné
vous avez dit qu'une partie des
la version plus courte marine le pen
manipuler l'information mathieu banon
mais je dis que je suis une ancienne
et c'est ça le problème aussi des
avez bien le droit j'ai le droit de dire
une deuxième point commun je m'adore non
victoires et chez de l'allemand était
en fait qui m'a dérangé c'est qu'on est
peut-être que grâce à ça on est encore
mais aussi de partager en temps
les range il était depuis c'est que les
réseaux sociaux c'est les mecs n'ont pas
mais je te dis mais c'est vrai que le
miss france j'ai jeu ça fait dix ans que
jugé et on sent quelque part que les
matin j'ai pas vie j'ai pas envie
raciste et vous devez l'assumer n'aurait
en vie quoi parce que c'est déjà une
que tous les gens qui votent front
mais je suis un peu d'accord avec
vous a demandé de vous excuser regardez
regardé ni le nil au meeting des manuels
parfaitement mais mais mais vous me
monsieur avec mourad effectivement je
tu vas pas tous les jours on a loupé il
fois d'être encore en vie aujourd'hui
propre et d'aller jamais passé mon temps
truc c'est qu'aujourd'hui il faut aussi
médias ou coup que l'état a la mainmise
d'habiter le village de si j'avais su
je véhicule les valeurs de la france qui
vois pas très bien j pardon comment on
macron ni ce que tu as dit dans
national attention regardez bien bien
avec après tout ce qui s'est passé le
répondez temps de parole calcul mais moi
à faire des objets
pour moi sont la liberté de pensée la
personnes aujourd'hui à cause de cette
je leur dis en face à tous ceux qui
j'ai envie d'habiter en france avec tout
comprendre voilà comme tu disais qu'il
sur les médias parce que ils ont pu
a ouvert une émission
complètement en élection si on est
peut douter juste effectivement il ya un
on ne peut pas retirer le préambule
pays est là le chômage a baissé julia
liberté d'agir la liberté de m'exprimer
pensée unique parce que les gens ont
pourquoi vous mettez on va affronter la
ce que ça représente et ça c'est
je vous réponds débat politique si on
couper pour ma part je parle comme il le
derrière tu te fais défoncer parce
pensent ça et qui votent front national
ya des gens aujourd'hui aussi qu'ils
postulat de départ il ya 1,6 puis après
la liberté de m'habiller je veux dire
peur de s'exprimer et ont peur des
sinon c'est retirer le sens je retiens
mondialisation elle est inéluctable
peut plus engager à ce moment là on
important je crois pour notre génération
qu'aussi il ya des ce qu'on appelle des
sont dans une très seraient extrême et
je leur dis en face regardez vous vous
voulait
savourer de les mains c'est bon
geipan dit qu'en soit la génération qui
il est phrase alors on peut soutenir ou
insultes que j'ai reçus y ait une pensée
pas possible mais où l'animal impossible
tout ce que je veux c'est pouvoir
plus ta clique vont mettre voilà
pagnon nous coupure alors donné
assez lassant mais selon lui
elle est inéluctable il faut que la
pas marine le pen mais là dans le
êtes raciste regardez vous vous être
qu'aujourd'hui comme thani ils se disent
à ce beau projet emmanuel macron jeu
unique sûr j'aurais tout sauf
tu vois ce que je vais faire chroniqueur
met l'extrême droite au pouvoir ont peu
décidera il ya des trolls
france se positionne dans la
discours là effectivement je vois pas du
on a on a on a tout fait et aujourd'hui
démocratique et que les gens qui étaient
il ya des règles oui il ya ya ya huit
compagnons
m'exprimer sans qu'on m'insulte alors
tout n'a pas été parfait moi le premier
mondialisation c'est l'enjeu de demain
au grand bleu tu vois je vais voir à
assis que les vouliez ou non vous êtes
déçu j'ai tenu des propos très violent
et chacun fait son buzz est au moins
je l'avais fait passer le message
tout du tout du tout il ya place à
on se retrouve toujours dans la même
dans la rue il ya deux mois ils vont
comment voulez vous vous positionnez
notamment pendant la période du
galère donc ça je le savais moi je j'ai
confusion après le débat il peut être
que moi je veux le meilleur pour mon
raciste
tout le monde arrive à vendre ces
ans avant l'élection où il ya des règles
contre le président dans les émissions
voter macro et ce sera les mêmes
quand vous vous refermez son vous même
j'avais une première extrait chez vous
pays et j'ai
confinement des restrictions de lui dire
j'ai tué je n'ai pas ménagé on peut être
ailleurs ces séries soient écartés des
journées ses papiers sais pas mais moi
comment voulez vous et si vous pensez
c'est ça il n'ya pas le diable pas le c
personnes qui seront à nouveau dans la
été moi tout ce que je sais de l'avenir
savez pas si c'était la version courte
ça serait quand même bien que vous
eu un parcours aux jeunes un parcours
vous pouvez pas faire parler plus encore
d'avoir été associée directement même si
grandes gueules tout ça je ne
rue et à quelques temps il ya quelques
déçu sensio c'est une chose mais on a
ou la version longue parce que pour moi
que le problème de la planète va se
derrière j'avais donc forcément c'est
compliqué aussi je veux dire à mes
disiez que c'est pas facile à prendre
la motivation pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a
d'excusés avec des avec des démontages
c'est un peu la même chose parce que
mois mathieu tu disais oui c'est pas la
parents sont venus en france dans les
mets sur blessure la phrase qu'il a du
pour un candidat avec un groupe plus
régler à l'échelle de la france si vous
que voilà c'est bien c'est bien jean la
une responsabilité en tant que français
comme décision parce qu'à décision
votre première phrase c'est les
pas diaboliser marine le pen avant
peine de faire des manifestations
années 50 pour pour faire le boulot
et où del cine 6r marine le pen plutôt
bientôt il y aura les urnes vous pourrez
comprenez pas que c'est un mot un
personnes qui votent autre chose que
et de tout ce que ça représente dans le
liberticide que vous les faites pour la
talent c'est à dire à des places gilles
macro sont des racistes c'est pour ça
que dire delphine wespiser est une
qu'on leur a demandé de faire à savoir
qu'un candidat qui avec de pénombre il
monde on a une véritable responsabilité
violence ou
santé des français mais précisé le de
manifesté à ce moment là clairement sauf
problème sur la planète entière quand il
citoyenne de 30 ans qui réfléchit à la
il faut pas la louper parce que les
que je vous ai demandé mais c'est parce
c'est pas les boulons les pluies les
faut les essais ça ya des règles c'est
préciser je suis pas fier quand je prend
maintenant au second tour on l'a
la délinquance alors vous êtes raciste
ya une partie de la population sur la
que là les gens deviennent nouveau
que c'est pas exactement ce que j'ai dit
gilles je peux tout étonné arguments en
plus valorisants je le comprends tout à
comme quand tu commences un jeu tu dis
diabolisé c'est la seule arme en fait
politique et qui ne veut plus de
amnésique en fait ils préfèrent
charges ne sont pas faites pour dimanche
ce genre de décisions parce que je sais
planète terre qui crèvent de faim et
je mesure mes propos je n'ai pas
maquereaux et donc qui prend
fait mais je n'accepte pas quand par
disant est ce que c'est pas une façon de
ça change tout seulement moi tu sais
prochain contrairement à ce qu'on peut
qu'on utilise parce que eric zemmour
manifester dans la rue puis paf en
il ya des règles nous on a commencé la
ce que je demande aux gens et je veux
insulter les gens qui votent front
l'opposition je suis désolé où est la
l'autre partie son problème ne pas
croire ce n'est pas joué mais je crois
la part du rassemblement national de des
exemple marine le pen se dit la
télé ici il ya des règles pareil on se
pas en abuser c'est compliqué à prendre
c'est indifférent le mois précédent
national bien sûr ou rassemblement
servi à ça voilà c'est clair qu'un entre
précédant les élections puis à nouveau
grossir en faisant le régime vous
phrase est un peu plus longue pour la
candidate du peuple des pauvres hier je
je crois qu'en fait pendant ces cinq ans
comme décision je trouve que là dessus
sortes de défendre ceux qui pensent que
national châssis mais je connais aussi
plie aux règles on va pas changer les
petite info été demandé à charge ni de
dans la rue et c'est ça moi qui me
marine le pen et zemmour je voter marine
malgré tout vous vous oubliez les gilets
comprends pas si vous comprenez pas
c'est sur twitter c'était un véritable
règles oui mais c'est la décision des
se sont un peu loupé vis-à-vis des
par moments ce que ce que se représenter
suis désolé l'a été elle était elle a
la génétique a une incidence sur
dérange parce que c'est plus de 60% des
le pen je m'en cache pas l'approcher
qu'il ya des équilibres qui sont
l'avocat de notamment dans la région
français voilà de dire voilà simplement
j'avais jamais connu ça comme des
grandes gueules elle était obligatoire
instables et qui va falloir le régler à
l'attitude on peut retourner arguments
quitter le pays mais je vais vous tuer
jaunes dont on s'est foutu vous oubliez
été levée dans le château de montretout
en place de messages de détresse ce vote
voilà on le fait mais attention on n'y
passions ouais en fait marine le pen va
personnes ne ne sont pas du tout
contre marine le pen contre marine le
marine le pen voilà évident parce qu'on
l'échelle du monde et pas l'échelle d'un
paul dit voilà et j'ai vu qui a fait une
moi j'ai été élevé dans les hlm ne
aussi
un sens 80e il faut tel qu'il faut de
d'accord avec cette politique là
les gens qui voulaient pas se vacciner
nous a envoyé le pire marine le pen
jean-marie tenir à notre question aux
montre rien donc
pays c'est que vous avez rien compris
envoyer aux chiens quelque part un petit
pen tôt pour diffusion de fausses
petite polémique et joue vraiment je
pourquoi est ce que un nombre très
qui avait peur on a emmerdé vous oubliez
prend pas plaisir à vous dire de rester
redonner de l'importance aux votes
c'est moins pire mais c'est pire il ya
là qui n'aiment pas le même parcours
écuries l'impression et moi je comprends
c'est ça l'enjeu de demain pour notre
défends botte des grandes gueules à fond
blancs tout simplement le vote blanc ça
chez vous enfermer voilà c'est parce
peu avec une fée cnous je suis bien
nouvelles ah oui c'est ça oui mon
toujours pire donc ça me va pas mais
conséquent votre est à nouveau c'est ça
très bien ce que vous expliquez vous
les histoires mckinsey qui est un truc
gilles verdez - droite je suis désolé
pays c'est se positionner ayant sachant
qu'on est inquiet face à une pandémie qu
pourrait vous lire oui ça pourrait dire
battement campagne électorale bien sûr
là dessus et moi 2 reviendra après
avez raison mais est-ce que c'est pas un
placé pour savoir ce qu'ils n'étaient
après vous savez moi je suis athée donc
on a un peu perdu on ne maîtrise pas
absolument abominable qu'on a mis sous
du loup layrac et j'espère qu'il nous
moi en fait que je que je comprends pas
qu être français c'est pas facile c'est
que je me souviens pas très longtemps tu
normal car on peut pas debout mais c'est
mais je suis pas extrêmement choquée du
c'était obligé c'est s&s et la reine ont
peu cas classique d'attaquer le ton le
reste un peu de temps sur son agenda
avais reproché de donner un temps de
quoi ce qu'est ce qu'elle reproche
en fait est-ce qu'il peut y avoir plus
pas facile d'être français parce que on
délicat voilà un sérieux
le tapis et qui est incroyable vous
montage café le rassemblement national
judiciaire pour moi mais en balade des
rn sur le racisme et sur ce qu'on lui a
sonné pour moi ya cinq ans j'ai été
parole hallucinant a exactement à eric
je suis très à l'aise voilà mais j'aurai
le chaos qu'aujourd'hui et encore une
a des ancêtres incroyable des victor
d'affinités plus la politique vaccinale
oubliez vous oublié la souffrance du
parce que je trouve que dans les médias
fois je le répète donc toute la presse
la religion pour musulmane pour moi elle
hugo à diderot de verlaine à baudelaire
reprochées depuis des années des églises
oies alors les grandes gueules dont vous
zemmour alors que simplement il y avait
oui oui oui entre autres mais mais mais
personnel soignant qui était déjà avant
soutien du président à bercy voilà et je
qui écoute s'il vous plaît arrêtez de
changement c'est que et et ça bien sûr
eu face à baba qui avait duré trois
que c'est pas finalement en faisant ça
est culturelle l epa cultuelle c'est la
c'est pas facile et quelques tout depuis
on fait parfois des raccourcis mais là
la crise ceux des pompiers ceux des
faites partie que nos amis des grandes
même les gilet jaune donc moi j'étais
heures et qui sur le mois de décembre
déformer mes propos on m'a dit je suis
quand finalement on l'aimé d'une dans le
savais que je devais me mettre en congé
s'est prononcée mais on pourrait
pas sur les ronds points mais mais mais
les médias l'ont passé en silence c'est
religion de mes parents je la respecte
que le monde est monde toutes les
gueules d'heure qu'on aime beaucoup et
polices et ceux des enseignants en fait
il n'est pas saisie sens pour moi ils
la seule personne publique qui s'est
des récits ont annoncé que vous étiez
ma maman fait le ramadan je respecte et
manipuler les chiffres revenir là-dessus
grandes idées ont été pensés en français
j'avais de l'empathie pour ces gens là
des grandes gueules le temps de riz le
mauvais camp serait que le raid
engagé pour marine le pen je me suis pas
que s'il y avait eu quelqu'un d'autre ou
ont supprimé une portion mais je trouve
certainement ce que j'étais tout à
voilà au bout d'un moment parce que je
moi j'ai de l'empathie pour des gens qui
écarté de l'émission après votre prise
et nous on a un héritage ces sept
temps de la campagne je trouve ça même
aujourd'hui il ya une boîte ils ont tout
engagée pour marine le pen je suis juste
par exemple mélenchon parce que dans
on nous a beaucoup ostracisé notamment à
que le fond de votre pensée c'est ma
sont au chômage parce qu'ils ont plus
fait pour être normalisées est-ce que de
sinon je trouve ça normal non je trouve
l'heure aussi avec une dent et juillet
français c'est à la haute être à la
tous les programmes il ya du bon et du
de position pour emmanuel macron samedi
engagée
cause des attentats je veux vous dire
droit d'aller fois que mourad et toi
vous dis ça parce que moi j'ai eu un
on traite les gens qui ont fait le plus
question est peut-être celui là est ce
mauvais personnellement étant donné que
hauteur de cet héritage de cette place
reparler de tous ces thèmes là qui font
ça normal parce que c'est la règle oui
flot d'insultés voilà ce que je voulais
vous avez un point commun vous avez
pour moi là dessus je lis je te le dis
je veux bien que tu dises et a eu raison
deux choses moi d'abord j'étais
parler d'eux eric zemmour il a fait
que vous n'êtes pas laissé un peu
mais peut-être qu'il faudrait un jour la
je ne veux pas reconduire avec le
qu'ils ont été en tout cas un fonds de
passé un week-end de merde pour des
dans le monde parce que chaque fois que
parler de lui et roman on a entendu
revoir
l'éditeur de charb et de tignes où je
emporter par le meeting survoltée est ce
commerce pour eux c'est pas un danger
la france décide quelque chose le monde
président sortant j'aurais voté pour
car on travestit leur conjoint en
parler que de lui sorti un truc par jour
moi tu y as bien 0 débat et à 0 dès la
quand même ça ressemble quand même et ça
parce que la hongrie ne m'entends
les ai lancé je les ai connus et
entier regarde et le monde entier copie
en faire une mise au point aussi oui
qu'aujourd'hui vous essayez pas de
quelque chose d'autre juste essayer
mais sur la question j'avais eu qui on
et il polémique par jour on est obligé
voilà donc voilà j'ai 30 ans je
rétropédaler en vous disant oh là là
fin j'aurais fait exactement la même
quelque chose d'autre c'est très
parfaitement ce que vous dites et je je
parle ces décors qui ont parlé et est
fatalement j'étais affecté lorsqu'ils
delphine alors bonjour bonjour moi je
c'est la règle je la connaissais par
d'en parler le soir s'ils savaient dès
j'ai dit tous les électeurs du r n était
important parce qu'ils ont tous leurs
je ne juge pas je reconnais parfaitement
m'intéresse à la politique je suis une
moins question que je passe que je bosse
leur ego la règle on a appris ça à mon
ont été tués par des gens qui ont un
points positifs et leurs points négatifs
aussi le courage de 2,2 et de delphine
raciste il était trop loin non
philippe poutou n'aurait fait philippe
citoyenne engagée j'ai le droit de
et c est ce qu ils ont tout fait pour
voilà et c'est bien sûr on est là à ce
suis très content de vous rencontrer
prénom qui ressemble au mien par des
absolument pas j'ai mis un préambule je
soutien d' emmanuel macron suis désolé
mais du coup pardon quid de delphine qui
être normalisées parce qu'il savait très
donner mon avis quand j'ai vu ce qui
poutou malawi et on nous a pas été
parce que c'est super ce que vous avez
que ça t'a porté préjudice que tu as dit
bien que ce n'était pas possible d'être
gens qu'un physique qui ressemble à
ah non non pas de taille à cinq ans
crois que lorsqu'on a des phrases
fait pour le milieu sportif et au niveau
dira je veux que marine le pen soit là
philippe poutou donc voilà c'est vrai
s'est passé ce week end alors vous étiez
les gens ça m'a porté préjudice les gens
élu avec les théories qui défend des
celui de mes cousins et je peux vous
la maman des lamelles et décomptés des
c'était le cas déjà non mais je suis moi
moi là je vais pas défendre ce que je
derrière on a un préambule et tout ce
business et tout donc je trouve ça cool
tous tout à fait tranquille moi c'était
dons qu'ils ont changé la vitrine mais
maintenant le job quand j'ai regardé la
la moitié sont telles que je soutiens
dire que pour toute cette génération
que l'on dit derrière et liés par ce
n'ai pas dit je n'ai jamais dit que les
un des pires week end de la ville où ce
les grandes gueules ils ont fait le show
l'écho qui prennent d'un côté et ensuite
peut-être que la boutique qu'elle aime
préambule et j'ai pris soin de le
télé j'ai vu une autre personne en fait
qui fait que j'ai jamais j'ai eu des
électeurs du front national était
dire quand vous lisez le front le plus
la comprendrait et j'aurais pris la même
milles les insultes des milliers de
être associé à ces gens qu'ils relèvent
répéter une fois ou deux en cours de en
le programme du front national et qu'on
raciste je dis simplement qu'il ya une
décision l'europe et à la coordination à
vous dit on va retirer 600 logements
la corrèze parce que le temps et des
typologie des lecteurs au front national
pas de la religion il relève de la
cours de discours parce que je m'en
psychiatrie pour moi plus de la
doutais bien il ya cinq ans j'avais
qui pense depuis des années qu'ils nous
sociaux à des étrangers en situation
psychiatrique de la religion je peux
j'avais déjà ceux tenus ni emmanuel
vous dire que c'est pas facile c'est pas
disent que il y a un lien entre la
régulière en situation régulière donc ça
macron j'étais à bercy et j'avais dit
simple et surtout les gamins à l'école
aux grandes gueules que si je me
génétique et la délinquance moi je pense
après les attentats du 11 septembre
veut dire six cent mille personnes
bonjour monsieur c'est la police pour
souviens bien un rmiste français est un
après les attentats à paris croient que
simplement que nous sommes le produit et
partir en général on vit à 3 dans un
c'est facile d'être un gamin et
anti par rapport à un migrant le front
comprenant étrangers à l'école alors
le résultat ne parcours social éducatif
appartement c'est un million 8 600 mille
qu'on entendra la journée déjà mais look
national le jour où j'ai été soutiennent
et culturel est qui a pas de lien et que
personnes on va retirer en mille le
[Musique]
[Rires]